[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up recon
welcome to the fallout 76 panel you guys
excited I see some really cool
cosplayers over there welcome yeah all
right ready to get started
I'm Jerry Steinman Oh somebody loves you
Todd you should all put your masks on
[Applause]
all right love it that's awesome
so I'm Gary Steinman and for the next
hour I'll be chatting with a team from
Bethesda Game Studios picking your
brains about fallout 76 getting the
answers to lots of questions questions
we gathered from a lot of you guys in
the community the tough questions that
they've been dying to hear answers for
but Before we jump in I'd love to play
the official trailer for fallout 76 the
one we debuted at e3 two months ago
because honestly I could watch that
trailer again and again and again so why
don't we all watch it together again
right now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
300 years after our great nation began
we gather together to honor the
completion of vaults 76 this sprawling
underground shelter may have been
engineered by voltic but it was built by
you so that if the bombs do come our way
of life will endure
yeah
Mountain
I
[Music]
country
[Music]
for when the fighting is stopped in the
fallout settled
you must rebuild not just walls not just
buildings but hearts minds and
ultimately America itself
[Music]
in volt 76 our future begins she doesn't
get old no it doesn't I mean clapping I
seriously I got goose bumps yeah it's
like a religious experience like a
communal experience hearing people
watching some of you sing along to the
song it's amazing yeah
stuck in our heads forever so let's get
started I'd like to introduce the team
here starting with the development
director Chris Meyer who who also
happens to be a local or extended local
you're right down the road in awesome
I've been there since 95 so yeah it's a
great city awesome project leader Jeff
Gardner
and of course Game Director not Howard
[Applause]
so and Gary well I introduce myself
well I'm Gary Gary I promise
tough questions and they'll come but
let's start with an easy one or what
should be an easy one Todd what exactly
is fallout 76 that's a good question I
mean the short answer is I think people
know fallout 76 is an open-world RPG set
in the in the Fallout universe that has
a lot of systemic and survival qualities
and the big difference with games other
games or games we've done are that there
are every character you see is a is a
real human that is playing the game and
that creates some really exciting
scenarios that we never can anticipate
you used the word systemic and we've got
Chris here who worked on one of the
granddaddy's of all systemic online
games Ultima Online and now you're
working on fallout 76 tell us about your
journey to work on this game but but
also your excitement your experience in
what you're bringing to fallout 76 in
terms of that kind of systemic online
game but Ultima Online is the reason I'm
in the industry it was the the first
game I worked on and how I cut my teeth
working on sandbox games with lots and
lots of players so it's a dream come
true to sort of bring that experience to
the Fallout universe which is a beloved
franchise for me personally and what do
you do so Jeff what do you do
hour to hour minute to minute in the
game I mean people know what fallout of
what a fallout game is and what you do
in a Fallout game is it similar here do
you have quest you have activities what
goes on you have quests ton of systemic
activities I mean it's very similar to
the fall you know and love the the major
differences obviously as you've heard
it's online and there's a lot of tension
created with other characters are they
friendly are they fun
we really dug into their survival
elements and the crafting elements of
the game the workshop and camp elements
so we really hope that it's really like
a place that once you're in it you're
sucked in for hours we find out work
like we just sucked hours go by and
we're like oh my god I got work to do
we're still playing the game so it's
wonderful yeah that's great I think it's
in people who who come to the office and
play it at first they're like this is
this is the fallout I know and love so I
think like 80% of it probably is the
fallout everyone is used to and the
other 20% is really different and it's
so it's it's times a little hard to
explain you know this is the flow and
how it feels because at one point it's
comfortable on the other side it's all
new which which brings me to another
variation on that question is this is
this the right game for Fallout fans
well I think so but I don't really know
there are so many types of fallout fans
right obvious everybody here and there's
so many things in our games and some
people love just the exploration the
character building the stories the
combat crafting and so it has all of
those things obviously the thing doesn't
have or NPCs that are gonna be specific
characters that tell you a story that
that we've written we love those things
we understand a lot of our fans love
those things and this one replaces that
with the other the other players they
are the interesting NPCs and hopefully
in a lot of ways more interesting than
what we may create on our own so that
part's very different I can't say it's
you know better or worse but you know
when you sit on played it feels like a
new Fallout game but there's no one type
of fall off and we've talked about this
around the office a little bit too
there's no one type of Fallout fan is
there no not at all and if you look you
know look at the old games you're coming
from an isometric more turn-based type
thing - what today is a you know it has
more adventure elements in terms of
exploring a world and what that means to
feel like living in that world and
that's something that still is very
important to us at the studio in terms
for the time you're in it it has to feel
real despite it being a video game and
your stuff like and that's what sucks
you in when we play it it's it's reached
the point in the office where really we
don't want to stop playing it has a very
slow burn but you feel like I am this
person in this world and learning how to
survive and learning how to conquer it
it's very rewarding the other big
question I have is why now why is now
the right time for an online fallout
well we figured we wouldn't do it till
we had done 70 more versions of fallout
so right 276 I don't know there's a good
answer for that we had talked early on
we had you know talked with Chris who
was down in Austin the team there we had
we had some ideas of what multiplayer
could look like we started that during
fallout 4 really on paper and and Chris
and some of the other folks in Austin
actually started before right when we
were starting to finish fallout 4 in
2015 to see you know how it could feel
what it could look like and it kind of
grew from there
yeah it was great it was taking you know
a game that we loved
fallout 4 and then actually grabbing
some Network code from one of our sister
studios it we're using the quake 3
networking architecture which is great
and then bringing it into the game and
then this one is for you Jeff you've got
you've got to heard many cats in your
role and now you've got these cats that
are not just in Marilyn and not just in
Montreal and not just in Austin but
yesterday we announced that we have bgs
Dallas as part of the family so you've
got a team spread across North America
[Applause]
how are you not pulling your hair out
well I am pulling my hair out but it's
you know it's amazing there's so many
talented people across these teams with
great leadership and you know there's
been a learning curve for me too it's my
first online game so I thought guys like
Chris Mayer who have done it for years
I'd really be lost at sea it's just it's
an amazing experience to be able to go
to Montreal and work with the folks who
are doing all the graphics and then back
down awesome of these gameplay and
network code out experts it's bringing
this all together in a way that has been
it's been a it's been a it's been a
three-year project right so it's gone
and gone and gone and we've done this
really quickly we iterate really fast
and everyone is really good about
communicating and we fall short here and
there but we all have what what's best
in mind for the game is always our
number one thing that ego so we always
focus on that goal and we're so excited
to share it with all you and for you
Chris you recently joined or relatively
recently joined the bgs family what's it
like the culture here and how was your
how did you adapt to to becoming part of
the bgs family once I got over the the
the awe of actually being a part of
Bethesda games franchise they make
franchises that I've loved forever
starting with morrowind but after that
adapting to their culture they're a very
iterative studio which I like I love
that we we play the game every day
sometimes all day and keep making
improvements every time we make a new
build and that's it's a great culture a
great thing to be a part of I love
working with all of these guys that's
great so you brought some new stuff Todd
and to be honest with everyone out here
I only saw this stuff maybe an hour ago
so it's still fresh to me to stuff about
the character progression and perks and
whatnot why don't why don't you tell us
what you know look through the questions
everybody has about the game one of the
big ones is how does the character
system work given that it's an online
multiplayer game so we have a bunch of
stuff to show you all in the game how
the character system works and what
we'll go through and explain it one of
the things that we're doing we showed a
little bit of it at e3 the you will
emerge videos from our friends at
vault-tec and so we've done these videos
for several sections in the game and we
thought we would show you first here at
QuakeCon the one that deals with perks
so we can roll it
[Music]
[Applause]
you
today's episode being a better you in
life we must each deal with the hand we
are dealt performing our assigned role
to the best of our capacities but after
total atomic annihilation you may find
the hand you were dealt has been
reshuffled yes
gone are the simple days of yesteryear
now the common workman must also be a
covert operative the farmer a master of
the martial arts the ice-cream man a
nuclear physicist how will you make
sense of it all simple turn to your
official vault-tec training materials
with these powerful tools in hand you'll
learn to make the most of your natural
abilities and better understand what
makes you special use them to be the
best you you can be or someone even
better your survival depends on it
with your future secure share your
newfound knowledge with great benefit
[Music]
but remember there's power in diversity
[Music]
sometimes who we are isn't a choice at
all in fact at a particular point in
your young life you may notice that your
body has begun going through certain
unfamiliar changes no it's not puberty
its mutation thanks to our old pal
radiation your DNA has become more
interesting see here you've now gained
the unique abilities of a marsupial in
exchange for a mild neurological
impairment now you've learned how to be
a better you
you are completely prepared to achieve
your full potential in the role of your
choosing as a hand-picked resident of
vault 76 it is your duty to carefully
review your vault-tec provided films
yearly to fully prepare for the day when
[Music]
okay Todd that was a lot of fun but I
think we all have more questions now
yeah it's will take a little bit of a
deeper dive here and there's there's a
lot to go through and we'll do our best
to explain it the video does a great job
of you know selling the IDS key parts of
it the mutation part you know it's
pretty fun your character can actually
get mutated but the the perk system and
how you develop your character we've
done a lot of interesting things there
but let's let's just jump right in and
show you a little bit of the character
creation when you first start you wake
up in the vault its reclamation day we
have a full you know customize your
character like we've had before it's
even better now and you get to take your
ID badge
we we've added this photo mode in the
game that's really really cool the photo
mode allows you to change your field of
view zoom in zoom out and you'll see all
the filters that are coming up you can
do this both here when you take your
badge it's like a training tutorial for
it then you can do it anytime you want
out in the wild with your friends with
dead enemies with a lot of enemies we
have also added this to our load screen
system there's not a lot of loads in our
game but when you fast travel there's a
little one and so any of the pictures
you've taken there will pop up like a
random deck with along with our curated
photos we really this is came out of a
game jam we do these game jams in the
middle of projects to see what new
features we want to try to get in and
this was one of our favorite ones yeah
it turned out turned out really really
great and fun for socially shareable
stuff to even offline your friends and
so you know again make your character as
a whole host of it you can take pictures
where you want you can also anytime in
the game change how your character looks
because you're gonna play a character
for a long time and you can you can swap
out change for sex anything your hair
everything just so that you don't feel
like well I have to I don't like how I
picked in the very first second what
look like and a really really cool
feature next we have will show you
stepping out of the vault and the first
level up and kind of dig into that some
so you get your if you hit level two
when you step out you kind of complete
the initial vault thing and the first
thing you do when you level up is pick a
special that you want to increase if you
played previous fallout so we have all
the seven specials and after you pick
the one you want to increase you then
pick a perk in that special so here
we're choosing gladiator which is a
melee perk and then that is a card as
you can see the perk system or the perks
are cards and then you equip those and
every special is a pool of points for
the cards you want to equip and each
card has you know I don't want to say
mana cost but a point cost for how
powerful that card is and do you have
the right special for equipping it right
and is it flexible or my jumping ahead
you have there's some more on that we
can get into and show you how flexible
it is and why we made some of the
choices that we we did let's keep going
and then we can spend some time we see a
more complete character okay this is a
level up to level four so we pick some
more cards we wanted to show you how the
cards themselves rank up okay so you can
pick that card again so by picking
gladiator again you can then combine
that card with the other one to create a
more powerful version but it costs more
points right sometimes you may decide
well I only want the one point version
equipped for my character build versus
the more powerful two point version
because I'm using my strength stats in
some other way and yeah so I think that
probably makes sense yes I hope but
there's more than four levels in the
game either yes they're the levels keep
going up and up and up we don't want to
make a game where you have to stop
leveling and but we had to make some
very interesting decisions and what that
means for a multiplayer game for balance
so let's let's run the next one where we
see it's a much higher level character I
think it's in the 40s
so here we are and you'll see a
character that's much further along
thinking charisma we can talk about
Christmas interesting yeah here's a perk
the less mutations act better with
groups and so you can pick any perk that
you meet the requirements for when you
level up there's no randomness there and
here's what it looks like with a
character that's further along we've
upped the cap for each special to 15
from 10 that allows you know better
balance for which cards you're equipping
and the cards right now go from one
point up to five points in power and
then as you level up more cards become
available I've got a bunch of questions
about that but I won there nope okay but
I want to ask about charisma should I
ask that later about good we can talk
about that now yeah yeah Chris how does
charisma work in an online game if we're
not talking about NPCs that you can
influence what what is what is charisma
do for you there was there was a very
interesting discussion amongst the team
to try to figure out what do we do with
charisma but it made sense in a
multiplayer game that a player that
invest points in charisma and collects
those cards they can share those cards
with their teammates so we've developed
a system where that that player that
invests can become the person that makes
your entire team more powerful by
sharing those cards we did throw a few
cards in there for the single-player I
think we have one it's lone wolf as I
recall on monitor a little wander right
right so if you can still pick some
charisma cards if you're more of a solo
kind of player but the person that plays
in groups all the time will probably
invest more there cool yeah and you
probably saw before again when you level
up you get these are the cards that come
in to the sets you can pick from when
you're level four or five whatever we
also experimented with well how do we
add some more fun to it and give you
more choices and so we have added
because their cards per card packs and
every few levels initially every two
levels you get a perk card pack and that
has a four random cards again you could
have picked these but it gives you some
more interesting choice that you might
not have picked
to give you some flexibility in in your
character and then later on you get them
every five but let's look at a per card
pack opening because they're a ton of
fun we do have gold that one's great
we have gold cards the anime of course
you get a joke and a stick of gum nice
and the gum actually for fun is a very
slight it reduces your hunger for a
while if you chew the gum and so there
there are a ton of fun you when you hit
that level and you're like oh it's level
six alright I get a pack you get to pick
your regular perk and then also see like
okay I got these other ones is there
something I want to swap out and that's
something good to talk about is the
swapping right of the perks right
because you mentioned that you know it
the packs help you discover something
you might not have known you wanted but
how flexible is a system jams like but
you can sorry Gary good you can swap out
perks anytime generally again to
reiterate when you level up you pick a
special you get a point in that special
which is the pool of points that you can
slot perks into you also get to pick one
perk per level you generally you'll pick
the perk from the special you chose but
you can also pick other perks if you
have available points and then these are
wild cards so every every two levels
from level zero month of time and then
every five levels laughter you'll get
one of those perk packs and what they
allow you to do is to experiment with
some other builds and cards you might
not normally a played remember you do
start with one point in each special so
you will have unused points from the
beginning to where you can try just
sliding these in right off the bat what
we have found is that that allows
players to go hey what are these luck
perks and why do I really want to search
containers for extra ammo and as you
play a survival gaming Bow Wow getting
extra ammo and containers is really
valuable and those remember you can also
share those perks so if you have perks
to share ammo and you share that on your
team every member of the team can then
find more ammo containers and these all
rank up so eventually you're getting
like huge bonuses amnon ammo or food
you're finding or your carry weights a
big deal on this game a lot of lot of
interesting back-and-forth with
developers on how much you can carry or
not and you know you see those cards at
first you're like well that's not as
cool as being able to do plus 20% damage
with my pistol but in a survival game
being able to carry more means you'll be
able to
carry more pistols so you know there's
there's a lot of ways that that
interplay and it's there are so many
cards in here hundreds and you're able
to really do these cool builds and swap
things in and out and then I'm on a team
I have a great perk for this team that
you know not want to carry one wanderer
is a perfect example of that
when wander are you what soon as I play
that when I'm playing solo all the time
because it gives me a bonus to my
experience and damage and as soon as
again I don't see my turn that off
because I'm on a team now it doesn't
work and I'll equip a different car that
I can share with my team so when you say
built you're not really talking about
sitting there and and having multiple
kind of decks you're talking about
having more of a baseline and then
making little changes here and there
quickly and easily is that is that a
kind of a correct way of putting it yeah
your character you're still progressing
the way you would expect in an RPG and
it's kind of growing and growing and
growing so it's kind of what Jeff was
saying you're swapping out a thing here
they're the perk packs can also
sometimes give you a perk that is we
intentionally do this you might get one
or two that from a pack of cards it is a
higher level than you are so it's like a
few levels in shooting distance so you
say like oh I didn't even know that was
a perk maybe I want to pick agility on
my next level up because the game has
given me this other perk and I just want
to try it out the other thing is this is
the multiplayer part of it that when you
hit level 50 you don't get to pick any
you don't get to give out a special
point anymore
so that doling out strengthen to all
that stops at level 50 but you still get
to pick cards so that gives us a
continuing thing where okay I hit level
73 and I'm still like you know what I
never got to pick that perk cuz again
there's hundreds of them I'll go pick
that one I want to try it out so you're
not but we're still capping the you know
the power curve ramp that in our other
games like a Skyrim or a fallout 4 just
like your character keeps getting more
and more and more and more powerful and
we knew we couldn't really have that in
this one yeah you talked about the
discovery of perks too and how you might
discover them in a card pack you might
see your friend using one that you never
thought you'd use have any of you in
your own internal playtesting found a
perk that you never thought you would
use that you're like wow this really
all the time anybody's an examples I
remember when I first started playing
the game I did exactly what what Todd
alluded to or Jeff where I've always
picked the the percent damage per I'm
thinking okay I just want to do more
damage as I played the game and
discovered there's a lot of value in
doing things like building up your camp
and doing a lot of exploration and
gathering resources I started to
actually take person I would have never
picked in a single-player game to reduce
the amount things ways that I could
actually carry more junk so I can then
bring that back to my camp and I find
that I'd swap that out a lot like if I'm
playing by myself and doing more
exploration I tend to use those kinds of
perks but if I play in a group we
typically have some objective in mind
it's something we want to go and kill
that I might swap some of those out for
the more traditional damage perks yeah
Jeff anything for you that that emerged
recently that you didn't think you would
use but now you're using particular I
did get one of those weird mutations the
other day though there are a lot of fun
too so I was playing and all of a sudden
when you have a lot of rads is when
you're susceptible to mutations like in
real life and then I got a mutation
called bird bone but I didn't realize
that got and often I was over quote
which is always a frustrating experience
in a game and I'm like why am i over
equipped and I looked and I had this
perk in that let me jump extra I put it
but it lowered my strength so I again
like the way the dynamic systems work is
incredible and you can spend a lot of
time in that perk menu but remember it
is a live game so make sure you're in a
safe place and then I have another
question who gets to write the jokes in
the gum wrappers that is mo PI Lulu are
you know he does all the master of the
the meat for a long time he wrote the
arrow in the knee there wasn't really a
joke
he came it became a poor guy and little
animal wrote all the
so let's switch gears I want to get to
some of the questions that we've
gathered up from the community I'm going
to call this the Thunder out usually we
do a lightning round but we've got a
half hour here we're going to take our
time we're going to Thunder through some
really tough questions that we gathered
up some from the community let's start
with a big one the beta mm-hmm now you
guys want to play am i right why can't
you let them play any sooner Todd
there's a lot of chatter I'll pack up my
stuff look we weren't everybody to play
it as soon as possible we're playing it
now there's a lot we have to do right we
wheat there's things that we know we
need to change and fix before we get it
in everybody's hands and the other thing
is even though people are gonna start
playing the beta in October this is a
game that we're gonna be constantly
updating so everybody's feedback is
really really important to us the beta
for us this is an all new thing right so
we need to stress test a lot of systems
and we're that's why we called it the
break at early test application because
this is going to break oh yeah we're
pretty sure that and get ready and and
so it's really we need to get make sure
we're ready for everybody comes in it
all crashes the first moment see I think
it sounds fun right it's really fun and
then you know making sure we're ready to
fix that really really fast and so that
we're in a good loop of hey here are the
issues let's fix them and Gary buddy
else in the game as soon as possible I
want to pick up on something you said
just to reinforce it you you mentioned
that this is a live game of course we're
going to continue to work on it your
feedback still matters because I know
that that was something that I think
some of the community were concerned
about yes everybody wants to play it
sooner than later and I'm with you but
you know you will continue to work on
this game or you have plans to continue
to work on this game and evolve it it's
not like it's finished and then you're
going to take one little round of
feedback you have lots
thoughts and plans and we don't want to
get into the roadmap but right we do
have kind of a roadmap in our heads and
this is a game that that we think with
the community is going to be a very
different game a year after it's out in
two years after it's out five years
after it's out it's a game in ten years
50 years it's we have big plans and what
we can do with the game and with our
community and the beta is just really
the the first step the first step the
next big one PvP I think everybody is
excited anxious concerned highly
anticipating nervous you've talked about
it a little bit here and there but why
don't you just take it from the top how
does it work
what's the deal with griefing how are we
gonna be able to enjoy our Fallout game
or how am I gonna be able to screw up
somebody else's fallout game and get
away with it or any variation on that
I'll just leave it to you this is why I
don't go on reddit all right we will do
our best to sort of explain where we're
coming from with PvP we agree with those
like we have folks in the office we have
that debate you know is it a you know
what is it where do we want the the the
players kind of driving for us is it a
PvE world thing is it the other players
and for us it is both how can we do both
and so the first thing I would say is
that we want this element of danger and
it sounds weird to say without griefing
which is like okay those things are
often in conflict so right now and
you've seen it in some of the e3 videos
when you shoot somebody you do a little
bit of damage you don't do full damage
it's like an imitate it's a like
slapping somebody in a bar okay
you want a fight and like that's
annoying I mean eventually you're like
yeah I think yeah we're gonna and so you
do little bits of damage if you engage
then you're doing full damage and
there's a cap reward based on the
players level so if the player is really
high level you're going to get more
captioning than therefore low level if
you want to after each one of them dies
you can seek revenge which doubles the
incentive so the guy kills you you're
like well that was annoying then the
game says hey if you want to seek
revenge
they're gonna give you the double reward
it's like okay maybe I want to engage in
that and that's really really fun the
issue is when you don't want to engage
in it right someone's coming up to you
and they're slapping you and slapping
slapping you and you're like I really
don't want to deal with this right now
we have a lot of ways you can get away
from them but we still like it where
they do if they keep going at it they
have the ability to kill you which
sounds terrible
something like why would you do that we
like to turn that into a dramatic moment
so the player that kills somebody that
didn't want to engage in it then becomes
a wanted murderer they get no reward
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's like the first applause of the
paper so there is no reward you get no
caps you get no XP you get nothing for
becoming a wanted murderer except for
the kind of social incentives people
have online to be [ __ ] which
evidently there's going to you so what
do we do with that we turn the [ __ ]
into interesting content so they appear
on they appear on your map as a red star
everybody sees them and they have a
bounty on their head in that that bounty
comes out of their own caps
and they can't see the other players on
the map and we did this we had this idea
like let's let's turn it like like let's
make them interesting content and it is
when this happens when anybody murders
somebody while we're playing in the
office everyone sees in the map and it
is like there it's awesome like yeah
that's one of my favorite stories there
so the other day we had a big test
internal test and we had played for
hours and towards the end of the test I
hit level about how it actually started
early and so I was higher level than a
lot of the other people and I saw that
red star and I was I was almost about to
log off and I was like oh now I'm gonna
get somebody so I had built a sniper
rifle
right I found a hunch a hunting rifle I
know super mutant and I built a little
scope and I extended the barrel and I
was like I finally get to use this so I
fast traveled near them now on the map
remember you see where they are it's not
super up it's it's a little relative so
it's not super pinpoint but you'll know
generally where they are so I'm sneaking
sneaking cuz when you sneak in our game
you're your appearance on the map
disappears no matter what state you're
in a separate wanted so I'm my pip
doesn't appear and I'm seeking I see him
in the building and I see moving around
and he comes wandering now and I took
his head off with my sector right he
drops down I go running up I loot his
junk
I dance took a picture over his corpse
and
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so what happens when you die though what
happens when someone kills you like
Chris wanted to jump in what like if
somebody if if I decide to engage or
even if I don't engage am i punished if
I die or there's got to be something for
a long time we tried testing where there
was no punishment at all and there was
and that took all the sting out of death
people will use it to their advantage to
travel back to the various points and it
didn't feel right but we didn't want to
to make it too punitive because we do
expect people will die and there's no
save games like a single-player game so
what happens when you die is you just
drop your junk and junk isn't its it
worthless you need junk to to build
things in your camp or to make better
guns or to make better armor so what it
does is it creates a loop where you go
out and explore you create some junk and
if you happen to die that's that's all
you drop you don't lose your your
awesome power armor or any of the guns
that you've collected but then you have
to make a decision is like was that
enough junk that I need to go back and
get it or is that something I can live
without and what what people will do is
they'll go back to their camp and
they'll they'll put their junk back in
their stash which is safe nobody can can
take things out of each other stashes
and we've also ceded the world with
stashes as well so if you know where
some of the stashes are that's always a
safe place to store the junk thing
you've collected so just enough so it'll
sting really deeply hurt and it's also a
little bit of a reward for for if you
manage to kill somebody there's usually
something there nice thing with junk is
it's nothing that you can't just reget
by if you just keep playing like that's
that pile of it you start exploring
you'll collect more so it's sort of like
well that was sunk time do I want to go
back and get it and it's that happens on
PvP so if you do kill somebody their
junk drops and you get to pick it up you
get the caps from them right you can
take the junk but yeah but it's just a
little grindy time and you got it back
if it's you know we like it we put it in
it's just enough to make it where before
you head into a dangerous area but
before this you just run into a dangers
there you don't really care there's no
penalty to deaths like it just fast
travel back
and once we did that you let's say you
just stopped a little bit like well
don't want to take a moment and like
collect myself store the junk before I
head into danger if anyone remembers
fallout 4 screws are very valuable yeah
if you've got screws in your junk you
want to store them yeah inside between
like this awesome looking gun or a desk
fan have equal
how does responding work by the way if
you if you if you die in a in a
dangerous area but can you respond
anywhere what what goes on there
responding always takes you can respond
anywhere you have a lock just like
Fallout 4 you can fast travel wherever
you'd like the closest point to you is
free and that's entrance to vault 76 is
free beyond that you have to pay caps
based on how far away it is from you so
if you decide you want to take that
opportunity to go away fire to a corner
of the map you're gonna pay a small cash
cost you know sinking of the vault going
back to PvP it doesn't kick in until
level 5 so that gets people into the
game a little bit and understanding it
before people start saying hey do you
want to fight you in a fight because
otherwise they'll just hang everyone
because people everyone comes out of the
vault
you would just like set up your camp and
all the turrets that happen for a while
remember for for people who have more
questions on PvP and can already see
some exploits that might not be fun we
do allow you to ignore and block players
too so you can actually when you die or
at any time honestly but especially when
you die we have an option therefore if
you're just done with that you can
ignore them for that session then they
can't see you on the map
they can't they won't be able to still
mess with you generally unless a unless
they can find you but this is a very big
game it's very hard to find people
unless you know exactly where they are
you can fast travel easily we also are
entering a pacifist flag so your bullets
won't do that slap to people so you
don't have to worry about I'm fighting
something some idiot jumped in front of
my bullets and tried to get me in PvP
we're we're allowing you to turn that
off two people were
abusing that in the studio yeah the
pacifist flag well no they would like to
you go shoot a creature and they would
jump in front of the bullet right we we
we had our QA a team is the QA team
several hundred people during one of our
sessions to be the biggest [ __ ] they
can one session we got a lot of good
notes out of that I think this key way
knows how to play the game
yeah they I do have one more question
about pvp which is if you are a higher
level character with higher level armour
higher level weaponry how do I even have
a chance and I get the slap mechanic but
if I want to engage and I'm a lower
level character am I just gonna get
destroyed instantly we did we struggled
with that so what we've done is there's
two sort of power curves you have the
usual power curve against creatures in
the world that you're used to in our
games and then so if you took a power
curve from like low damage to high
damage in PvP we normalize it okay so
the like just a knife is gonna come up
and damage and the really powerful thing
is gonna come down so they feel right
but the death and PvP is is quicker and
it works the same for armor so if you
play other multiplayer games the guy in
power armor with a minigun is obviously
gonna be harder right but if you get the
drop on him with a knife it does kind of
work and it makes it more fun without it
being well I have no chance whatsoever
again there's still a ramp there it's
just you know normalised cool new and
you get the caps alright so that's the
other thing is do I why do I want to go
try to kill a level hundred person and
power armor with my when I'm low level
is that my reward is going to be way
higher excuse me nukes very cool it's a
little feature
but what happens when we're new I mean
we know that things happen we know that
the the area gets irradiated things are
destroyed there's higher-level loot
higher-level enemies but let's say I
have a camp in in that area what happens
to my camp how soon can I rebuild it
yeah we first of all nukes are very cool
all right they're they're one of the
coolest things that happen in the game
but we we don't want it to be overly
burdensome to a player to lose all their
all their stuff so that we don't when
when you nuke a camp it does destroy the
structures but we've created something
called a blueprint system so that if you
spend you know hours making a really
cool house with lots of detail you can
blueprint that house so it's very easy
to replace it in the event that it gets
destroyed by a nuke it also makes it
very easy to move your camp so even if
we're not talking about destruction with
with nukes if you decide you want to
relocate your camp to a different part
of the map and you can pack it all up
and you can put it somewhere and of
course the terrain is going to be
different but because you've blueprinted
your house and you can usually find a
way to to Jimmy it so that looks good
when you're replacing it so it's very
easy to get back to where you were so
you know the other thing with that is
that the camp destruction part is really
it's easy to repair it if you want to
leave it where it was but we did the
camp restriction exists it's not really
for like hey go blow someone's camp up
we realize when we put it in that that
is a griefing mechanic is like someone
who wanders by and then you build a camp
and you like imprison them now they have
no way to get out so they need an
ability to damage the walls just to get
out of the prison you have built for
them right so it has less to do with hey
we want other players to come and blow
them up the camp is also good for PvP
where someone engages with you and you
lure them back to your camp there's
Ashley Chang in the studio you can build
like musical instruments and he's he
built his camp and he's sitting in the
middle of a road playing a tuba huh and
he's on his platform and he had built
all these turrets in the foliage you
can't see
and everywhere just like this guy into
like and then the Curt just like killin
everybody's are the whole time awesome
a fair where I was headed with that I
don't know I don't know with the NGO
their second with PvP stuff right and
the other thing with moving it around
that was key because the game so big you
come out of the vault and you find a
place you're like this is where I'm
gonna build my camp and then you play
like four more hours and you're like I
shouldn't like this view I like this
place better so people tend to put their
camp down and then as they progress
through the map they are finding new
areas and then they kind of settle in
like okay I really like this spot so you
move through the world you meet friends
you're playing with others how does
communication work because I know that
you put a lot of thought into that and
that's even involved a lot in recent
days months weeks it has we and this was
in the e3 stuff where we had the emot--
wheel we have where you do you can
emot-- and we have the you know the
vault boy cartoon it's really fun
we were big on communicating in a nice
way with strangers and that that's we've
had some successes there but we have
found that we weren't giving the other
players even if they were strangers and
the ability to really be as interesting
as we wanted so now we're adding you
have you've we've had voice chat for
your teammates and now if you want to
turn on your mic we have voice chat for
all of the strangers which which really
lets them communicate and it's very very
different dynamic in the game area base
so people around you will hear you talk
and commute that to any interesting
chatter around the office in your own
playtests anyone in your own playtests
any there's always interesting chatter
and there's always cool photos that
people are putting up from photo mode
it's a really fun game to play with
people I think I remember was just a few
weeks ago I got to a point that was was
really hard so I waited till lunchtime
and then gathered a bunch of people's
like hey I you need to come help me with
this part so I get a bunch of people
logged in at lunch and then we go on
kill the super mutant sir cool let's
talk about that how exactly does vas
work if it's an online game it's more of
a real-time everything's happening in
real time what
what how does fast work it's it's real
time we now initially you can't target
body parts that's a perk okay because
it's real time like getting all the
parts at first is kind of hard so we did
it where did you get the whole body you
get the percentage based on your
perception and it's incredibly
incredibly useful and so we did that and
it plays really really well so we're
happy with it's not just useful to
target and hit enemies it's also to find
them yeah so you use that a lot to try
to you know I heard something shoot I
mean where is it because obviously the
game is certain areas much more lush
than our previous games so things are
very high D you don't know quite where
they are I mean the thing I personally
love about bats I'm not the most skilled
twitchy player so it allowed me to
become a much better player and a game
like fallout I mean is that something so
so for those who aren't engage in combat
does it still help them in the same way
it does because it's based on your
perception and perception starts at one
now right it's not as useful out of the
gate and but then if you the point is if
you invest I'm a perception character
those percentages do cross a line where
oh my gosh I'm definitely more accurate
using this than I am just doing it on my
own and we try to strike a good balance
there an easy question I think we might
have even mentioned it in the past but
who's doing the music for for fall out
so he non-0 who's done the music for our
other games he's amazing the soundtrack
is spectacular
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and we have a lot of licensed music as
well so we have more tracks than we've
ever had in a Fallout game so there are
radio stations you can listen to
something we've loved in the series and
it's always fun to go through and say
like okay what are the classic tracks we
want to have and then there is an
unbelievable amount of just bizarre old
40s music like oh yeah there's some
wacky there's some wacky stuff it's
great for fallout so sometimes it's like
hey what's the mood of this song and
then other ones are hey this is the song
that has you know this kind of you know
the slant on the lyrics as it appears
and fall out when it's post-apocalyptic
make it really fun
we know fallout 76 is an online game
this question has come up a lot on
places like reddit what about private
servers that is definitely something
that we are doing we're committed to it
modding for us such as having a private
server it's being able to mod it so mods
for us have really been you know once
our games come out that that's what our
our hardcore players play and they're
still playing you know Skyrim and
fallout 4 to them still most popular
games in the world and a lot of people
are playing mods and so that is
something that given the online nature
of it is gonna be very very complicated
but we're committed to it and we've been
you know starting to design what that
system is going to look like but it is
it is you know it's a I will say this
it's a complicated problem but one that
we are a hundred percent committed to
solving
I I think that wraps us up I think we we
got through the questions we had any
last words for the audience about
fallout 76 what you're excited about
what you want people to experience I
just can't wait to see all these people
in the game absolutely we can't wait to
play with you guys I would say really
it's you know seeing everybody here and
what our fans have meant to us this is
the part of our excitement you know
whenever we do a game we try to make the
game that we would really want to go out
and buy ourselves and this one is very
very different for us we know it's
different for our fans it's also the
first game that we can really experience
with them and that that part of it is
really important to us and I don't think
people really understand how exciting
that is for everybody at all the studios
it's exciting for all of us Thank You
Todd Jeff Chris thank you for being here
thank you all for being here fall comes
out cause it's about November 14 on
PlayStation 4 Xbox one and PC we'll be
sharing a lot more information soon
thank you and a big round of applause
for our panelists thank you
[Music]
[Music]